Sri Lanka where students have been
marching in the capital of Colombo to
demand the release of activists detained
during last year's anti-government
protests they say they're in prison in
amounts of political persecution last
year's demonstrations were sponsored by
the country's worst ever economic crisis
lifetime correspondent menel Fernandez
in Colombo but now there's been quite a
lot happening behind you there in the
last few minutes tell us about the
situation and how tense this protest is
we're literally out of protest by
University students on the outskirts of
Colombo the SRI Java danapura campus
where students have been protesting
against the government against
repression basically asking the student
leaders be released if you can just look
over my shoulder literally within the
last two minutes we've had volleys of
tear gas canisters of which you can
probably still see the water cannons uh
just because the main road is literally
about 10 meters down and you had the
marching groups of University students
marching on this wall of police of
special task force Commandos all armed
with water cannons and several tear gas
canisters now they have scattered for
the moment but University students have
said that this kind of repression by the
government is not going to be able to
stop them and silence them so what
they're saying is that the government
sort of campaign to repress the people
to silence their voices to stop the
University Cities protest movement which
was so involved in that anti-government
protest we saw last year which led to a
change in the government the the
University students say it's not going
to happen they're not going to back down
and so what are their demands exactly
and what has the government responded
right if you're able to tell us of
course the police actually if I can just
take a minute
yes the police is marching on the
protesters uh followed by the two water
gas uh the the water cannons uh the
those in the camo are obviously members
of the special task force units and
police that are Marching on the students
now you asked me about what the demands
were this is very much still happening
you can see the volleys of water uh
people all of these security Personnel
armed with shields with tear gas masks
and buttons and there we go we've we
seem to be just under one of the tear
gas wallets and uh
okay now we're gonna let you go for I
don't know if you can see that yeah we
saw that on the camera
uh if you're able I think that's water
cannon but if you're able to just still
keep that talking to us about this uh we
will continue but if you feel unsafe
we'll let you go
I I am fully I'm quite happy to keep
keep talking about the situation uh as
as you can see this is the kind of
reaction that University students that
protesters are facing every single time
they take to the streets now we've got a
first-hand experience of it but this is
what the situation is with the
government going way over the top in
terms of cracking down on any form of
protest and descent uh there were two
court orders that were obtained earlier
on against some of the student leaders
as well as some of the student activists
against allowing them to actually lead
some of the Marchers into the city near
the president's house and things like
that but here uh the the police has
actually if I can show you
um chosen to Circle this University
where the sort of assembly point was and
try to keep them from moving even Beyond
this point if I can just show you the
water cannon and the far distance they
seem to be topping off the water and in
the water cannon and there's tear gas
there's a tear gas cannon that seems to
be a bit of a damp squid but if I can
ask the cameraman to tear gas cannons
that istia gas is what you're seeing
right now
a tense situation in Sri Lanka's Capital
this are you now Fernandez correspondent
reporting there live from the scene of a
confrontation between police and
protesters student protesters who've
been demonstrating in Sri Lanka's
Capital demanding uh the release of
students who were detained in previous
demonstrations against the government
tear gas and water cannon being used
against the protesters there and on our
team as well as you saw will keep you
across the story in Sri Lanka as more
information comes through of course